[Music]
as president total Trump has signed two
bills into law that back Hong Kong's
pro-democracy movement American
sanctions can now be imposed on Chinese
and Hong Kong officials deemed
responsible for human rights abuses
head-on Kong special trade status will
be reviewed every year territories
leaders say it'll damage relations with
the US while China's expressed extreme
regret over the move saying it will
respond with firm countermeasures Paddy
cocaine's been following developments
from Washington this could be a powerful
tool if the president chose to use it
it's not at all clear he's going to not
only does it let him sanction people in
Hong Kong and China but it's that
special trade status that could be so
critical if the secretary of state was
to come back and say no China is not
going along with the policy Hong Kong
doesn't have enough independence they
could basically take that status away
that would have a huge impact on trade
but bigger than that it could send a
signal to financial markets to investors
that Hong Kong is not a safe place to
park your money so that is the big
concern it does seem unlikely that
they're going to take these steps the
other bill that the President signed
more concretely it stops American
companies from giving or selling any
thing to Hong Kong authorities that can
be used against crowds such as tear gas
canisters or rubber bullets so exactly
what the president is going to do it's
not clear Congress has given him this
authority he has sent the signal that he
doesn't want it to use it so we'll wait
to see what the Secretary of State says
but for this president the big concern
is the trade war he needs rural America
to get reelected and right now they're
really hurting because of this trade war
an amendment we'll talk to Sarah Clark
in Hong Kong first let's go to Andrew
Thomas in Beijing and of course him
Andrew the timing here you know this is
all happening while the US and China
have been in this extended trade war so
what is the reaction out of Beijing well
the practical measures and the potential
sanctions are one thing but what Beijing
has already reacted to is the mere
consent by Donald Trump to this US
Senate legislation and the symbolism but
all that represents and what Beijing has
said already first thing Thursday is
that this is encouraging the violence in
Hong Kong they
a very long a very strong statement I'll
read little bits of it here the US has
been disregarding facts and distorting
truth it openly backed violent criminals
who rampantly smashed facilities set
fire and assaulted innocent civilians
and they are suggesting that with the
formal passing of this act
it will give encouragement to the
protesters in Hong Kong quite apart from
any practical measure that sanctions in
time may have now they're also saying
that this isn't just about Hong Kong
either this is all part of a concerted
effort Beijing feels by the US lawmakers
to undermine China as a whole this
statement goes on this acts will only
further expose the malicious and
hegemonic nature of u.s. intentions to
the Chinese people it's very aim is to
undermine Hong Kong's stability and
disrupt the Chinese nations endeavor to
realize the great renewal so a really
furious statement here which concludes
with a pretty well not very veiled
threat at all that China will take
countermeasures it's unclear as yet what
those countermeasures will be the
statement says that the US will bear all
responsibility for those consequences we
may find out a little more in two hours
time when the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs here in Beijing holds its daily
press conference but for them to have
put out a statement that long and that
strong and that's swiftly really says
how angry Beijing is about this okay
enter Thomas at the latest from Beijing
Hong Kong pro-democracy activist Joshua
Wong says the US has shown it will
prioritize human rights over a business
for US president signed on the Hong Kong
human rights and democracy Act that's
the remarkable achievement of all the
Hong Kong's no matter
Democrats or Republicans the new
bipartisan consensus from both the US
administration and Congress is to stand
with Hong Kong to Piratas human rights
and democracy and not being override by
the trade negotiation Sarah Clark mentis
live from Hong Kong so let's put all
this in some context well what else are
you hearing there about the reaction in
Hong Kong obviously to Joseph Wong
Joshua Wong rather is pretty pretty
enthusiastic about it
well the pro-democracy movement will
consider this a victory in light of the
ongoing protests that have been here for
around six months this is a small wind
but certainly one that they will embrace
and the government however has responded
strongly it's objected to this act now
becoming law it says it deeply regrets
the decision by Donald Trump to sign the
Hong Kong human rights and democracy Act
they say this regards the genuine
concerns of the the people here in this
city and it also interferes in Hong
Kong's internal affairs so the
government here is pretty much told the
u.s. to butt out of the the matters that
concern the residents here that the
words they've used unnecessary
unwarranted and will harm relations
between Hong Kong and the United States
it also says it sends the wrong message
to the people they've described as
violent protesters now on Thursday we
have another rally expected tonight and
now this rally was all about at the Hong
Kong human rights and democracy act and
the fact that Donald Trump has signed
it's on the same day I will no doubt
boost morale for the protest movement
and could also attract a bigger numbers
as a result okay Sara Clark with the
latest from Hong Kong
Sarah Thank You mr. Chang as a political
scientist in pure democracy campaigner
who's the founder of Alliance for true
democracy he joins us via Skype from
Hong Kong so let me ask you about what
Sarah was just saying that this has the
potential to really motivate the the the
protests and the end the pro-democracy
protesters do you agree with that yes
this is a very significant morale
booster for the pro-democracy movement
in Hong Kong it also indicates that the
international community including the
American public will assess seriously
the nature of the Chinese communist
regime public opinion pressure regarding
human rights issues in China will
probably become rather significant in
the presidential campaign to come in the
United States but we also have to
realize that there is still considerable
room of maneuver for Donald trum and for
China at this stage the State Council
will send its report to US Congress in
one year's time the US Congress that
makes recommendation
the white house to my house Ben decides
what actions to take so Chinese
authorities are more concerned with the
public opinion trends in the United
States rather than with concrete actions
on a part of the Donald Trump
administration today said is exactly why
they have not responded with serious
retaliatory measures at the moment so
you mentioned the the presidential
election and how human rights and things
like that might be an issue but often
wood is more of an issue no matter what
the country is the economy and the trade
war that's going on with China has has
not been good for farmers in the u.s.
might you see a possibility of Donald
Trump although he has signed this into
law not really putting his weight behind
it because he has other concerns agree I
think the trade associations are going
on and both sides are very serious with
the negotiations and they do not intend
to let a Hong Kong issue to adversely
affect the negotiations the Hong Kong
issue is not new today it has been going
on for six months and trade negotiations
have also been going on both sides do
want to have a trade agreement and
intermediary stage agreements to satisfy
domestic needs but both leaders are
concerned that they must not be seen to
be making too many concessions to the
other side and the other problem of
course is the lack of mutual trust
between the two governments what
realistically as you pointed out at
these protests have been going on for
six months and the initial things that
the protesters want they got but then
the list expanded what realistically do
the protesters who spoke pro-democracy
movement hope to get out of China the
posters and the pro-democracy movement
understand the China probably will stick
to his hardline on Hong Kong and
therefore you cannot expect much from
time is leadership law from the Carrie
Lam administration most Hong Kong people
however feel that they have their base
nine concerning human rights freedom
liberty rule of law and so on and they
believe that they should articulate the
position now that they have the
opportunity they would continue their
protest to expose the lack of legitimacy
and representativeness on the partner to
carry the administration and to
demonstrate that you cannot govern
effectively in this way Joseph Chang
joining us from Hong Kong thank you very
much sir